Коли з'являється він,
починається рух.
Проведення часу кайтера —
це очікування вітру.
Ми завжди його чекаємо,
ми його ловимо, ми його любимо.
Вітер!
Це для того, щоб викликати вітер.
Ось ми під'їжджаємо до нашого
гоум-споту [відправної точки].
Ягорлик з боку села Іванівка.
Найбільш дикий спот України.
Ось так починається наш ранок.
Приїздимо на спот.
От.
Вітаємося з морем.
Коли я поїхав на дошці вперше,
я пам'ятаю це відчуття.
Коли тебе тягне якась сила —
це відчуття, що ти керуєш стихією.
Я є керівником школи кайтсерфінгу «Вітролов».
Ми влітку вчимо людей водному кайтсерфінгу.
Ось тут, на березі Ягорлицької затоки.
[Роман проводить інструктаж з кайтсерфінгу]
Ліву, праву.
Оце уявна середина в тебе, оцей строп.
Ага.
І ти натискаєш як важелі,
від цього стропа.
Ага. Праву, ліву.
Праву.
Ліву.
Кайтсерфінг для України — це вид активності,
який під собою має на увазі...
Ти катаєшся на дошці завдяки кайту.
Це означає «повітряний змій»
у перекладі з англійської.
Він генерує тягу за допомогою сили вітру.
І на дошці по воді чи по снігу
можна кататися увесь рік.
Головне — щоб був вітер.
У 1980-х роках брати Легеню,
французи, сертифікували кайт.
І з того часу кайтсерфінг вже
офіційно став видом спорту.
В Україні, як і багато видів активностей, починається все
з якоїсь групи людей-адептів цього виду спорту.
Приблизно на початку 2000-х років люди
почали пробувати ці повітряні змії.
Їм якось потрапляли вони з-за кордону.
Вони навіть не знали, як запускати
кайти, вони експериментували.
Інструкцій не було,
YouTube у ті часи особливо не було.
І як з ним [кайтом] поводитися,
ніхто не знав.
Кайт дуже вимогливий до умов,
потрібні стабільні вітри.
Нам потрібно багато простору,
мілководдя на морі.
Ягорлицька затока — це саме і є мілководдя.
Приїжджати треба в правильне місце,
на правильну локацію —
це є херсонські споти.
Вліво підемо.
Передстартова позиція дуже важлива.
Вирівнюєш себе.
Планочку трошки привідпускаєш вгору,
щоб він вийшов до зеніту.
І вправо різко!
Чекаємо, чекаємо, чекаємо, чекаємо.
І оп! Давай!
О!
Добре! Все, відпускай!
Почалося все з того, що я приїхав
одного разу в Крим, до друзів.
На озеро Донузлав.
І кайтери високо стрибали,
вони робили неймовірні трюки.
І я зрозумів, що я хочу
бути одним з них.
І для мене дійсно почався кайтсерфінг,
коли я вперше злетів під кайтом.
Коли ця сила виштовхує тебе вгору,
і ти нею керуєш...
Це відчуття необмеженої радості,
що в мене вийшло це.
І це я зміг зробити.
І вирішив з колегою (у мене був партнер)
заснувати свою школу.
У нас взагалі школи кайтсерфінгу
в Україні мають кожна свою локацію.
Тому, припустимо, якщо
говорити про Іванівку,
то всі знають,
що тут база «Вітроловів».
Я себе тут відчуваю, як вдома.
Місцеві жителі нас
називають «парашутистами».
Вони кажуть: «Рома-парашутист».
От мене називають
«Рома-парашутист».
[сміється]
Хоча кайт — це зовсім не парашут.
Я жив десять років у Києві до того,
як переїхати в Іванівку.
Я займався...
У мене був невеличкий онлайн-бізнес.
Я був керівником проєкту.
Ми писали під замовлення бізнес-плани.
Також паралельно я інструктував
по сноубордингу, по вейкбордингу.
Це як допи [додаткові види діяльності] були.
Маркетологом також працював.
Трошки поміняв так діяльність за десять років.
А потім вже, коли підійшов
до питання школи кайтсерфінгу,
я зрозумів, що потрібно
займатися чимось одним.
І наразі це моя основна діяльність.
Я більше нічим не займаюсь.
Добре, почекай.
Виводь кайт у зеніт, чітко в зеніт.
Будемо вліво стартувати.
Привідпускай трошки планочку,
коли він в зеніті.
І давай двостороннім махом, так?
І на моє «Оп!» будемо зупиняти
кайт на 45 [градусів]. Добренько?
— Ага.
— Давай, поїхали.
Різко вліво, чекаємо-чекаємо і оп!
Праву руку!
[аплодує]
Єєєєє!
Клас!
Люди почали підтягуватися.
З кожним роком більше й більше.
Вони приїздять, навчаються.
І знову повертаються.
З кожним роком росте сім'я «Вітроловів».
[сміється]
Це єдиний вид серфінгу, який,
так би мовити, доступний в Україні.
Це кайтсерфінг, ну і ще віндсерфінг, і все.
Робота з вітром.
У нас хвиль немає,
по яких можна кататись,
тому кайт набирає обертів.
Чи це є екстремальним
видом спорту? Ні.
Коли людина стартує на дошці
і просто катається — це вид активності.
Тобто не потрібно якоїсь
особливої спортивної підготовки.
А коли людина вже починає
стрибки, то так,
там вже потрібно трошки
в спортивний режим входити.
В Україні все більше й більше
людей стають активними.
Тобто відходять на другий план
якісь речі такі...
Посидіти в кафе просто
чи почілити [відпочити] десь там.
Люди прагнуть розвиватися.
І в такому напрямку,
як активні види спорту, теж.
І більшість людей, саме ті, які приїжджають до нас,
у нашу школу, вони саме такі.
Закохані в активний спосіб життя.
У нас збираються люди-адепти дикої природи.
Їм подобається просто екотуризм.
Вони багато подорожують.
Хтось був на Кінбурнській косі.
Вони знають цю місцевість.
Їм подобається оця діч.
[сміється]
В Іванівці саме такі умови.
Для мене баланс — це тоді,
коли немає нічого зайвого.
Є тільки вітер, вода, ти.
І все залежить від тебе, наскільки
ти зумієш осідлати ці стихії.
Як відбалансувати себе?
Якщо ти зробив все правильно,
відбалансувався — ти поїдеш на дошці,
ти зловиш свій вітер,
зловиш свій фан.
У кайтсерфінгу теж немає нічого зайвого.
Якщо ти щось робиш зайве,
то ти не поїдеш на дошці.
Моя справа як інструктора —
прибрати це зайве.
Давай вирівняй себе, Танюшка.
Перпендикулярно вітру.
Так.
Ага, тримай.
— Ну що, поїхали?
— Поїхали!
І вправо різко!
Чекаємо-чекаємо-чекаємо. І, оп!
Давай!
[вигукує і аплодує]
Клас! Привідпускай!
Моя справа — це стиль життя.
Я просто по-іншому жити не вмію.
Я вирішив поєднати
свої хобі зі своєю роботою.
Мені вдалося.
Я зловив свій баланс у житті.
І я розумію, що людина, якщо займається своєю
улюбленою справою, то все вдається.
Насправді.
І людина знаходить цей баланс.
Зрештою, це монетизується,
і підтягуються люди.
Якось так працює, напевно, всесвіт.
Я думаю, так.
[сміється]
Україна — це моя земля.
Саме тут я хочу розвивати свою справу.
Я не хочу нікуди переїжджати,
там будувати кайтшколу.
Я хочу на Херсонщині, у своїй рідній Іванівці,
побудувати класну кайтшколу.
І я думаю, що це в мене вийде.